[Music]
taxi driver but who the hell else are
you talking talking to me it really goes
back to brain De Palma it's independent
cinema in Hollywood started saying hey
maybe these indie films could these kids
could work in the industry and so we
were all out in LA and he introduced me
to Paul Schrader Schrader wrote Taxi
Driver Travis comes from his vision but
more psyche I connected with it through
dostoevsky's Notes from Underground it
was like enlightening you know and so
for me when I read the script Brian gave
it to me he said you know I can't I want
to do it I can't do it but maybe you
should do it but I didn't have enough
cachet as they say at that time to make
the picture but then they saw the rough
cut of Mean Streets and they changed
their mind
especially when they saw De Niro in it
and so they said for the two of you
we could probably get this film made why
would you talk to them why don't you
answer my calls when I call you think I
don't know you here we kept thinking in
terms of the character and his
loneliness and his acting out not
condoning the acting out but he does act
out and yet an empathy with him which is
really tricky we wanted to make it so
badly nobody would make it that we've
been thinking of going to different
cities to make it San Francisco the taxi
driving wasn't the same and we said no
it has to be Manhattan ultimately what
stayed with us was the psychological and
emotional state of that character as we
know now tragically
it's a norm every other person is like
Travis pickle now for me the
visualization of the movie was to always
try to keep you off balance keep the
audience off balance I felt that when he
made that phone call it was so painful
we shouldn't witness it so the camera
should track away but not pan away
it should move completely to a hallway
and in the hallway you think somebody's
coming but nobody's going to come
nothing's going to happen
we're all alone but we don't want to
experience the depth of his pain at that
point and at the same time
there's a sense of anxiety on the viewer
what's going to happen in the hallway
well apparently nothing that was the
first shot it came up by so that's the
style there's another thing too with a
taxi pulls up at the beginning of the
film into the taxi garage taxi is coming
in with panning with it as it comes in
and normally it goes this way in the
camera would pan with it and it stops
well as it came in I went the other way
and as we rested the cow came in and
stopped wait I'm supposed to be looking
at the car no we're going to go another
way and so every shot as much as
possible was
designed to be slightly
disconcerting But ultimately ultimately
satisfying that was the philosophy of
the the shooting
[Music]
Gangs of New York us natives born right
wise to this fine land
or the foreign hordes defiling it well
gangs in New York comes out of there
those cobblestone streets around the the
church on Mott Street and Mulberry
Street and also coming off the other
element that I grew up with really was
the Bowery at that time the Bowery was
what you call now homeless at that time
really basically alcoholics guys dying
in the streets basically very very
difficult place to grow up around and in
and so but there was something about
that Bowery and something about the
neighborhood and the way the buildings
were created in the cellars the sellers
there's so many Sellers and my father
would talk about growing up there going
into one building going down the cellar
and coming out two blocks away running
away from the cops or some of the guys
here it had its own life it had it was
like an organism and it had a history
well then we got business
in fact we do what Leo DiCaprio was
interesting because De Niro we were
acquainted with each other when we was
16 years old so because of my
relationship with him going back to when
we were 16. he um experienced what I
experienced growing up so he's the only
one I know around who's around that and
who was working in that capacity that
knows who I am where I came from and the
world we were in he then called me and
said at one point he just made a film
called This Boy's Life and he was
working with this kid that he he cast
named Leo DiCaprio said he's very good
he got to do work with him someday and
Bob never really used to tell me that
work with somebody you know just go from
picture to picture if we work together
DiCaprio uh liked our pictures came
together and they said why don't we
you've always wanted to do gangs in New
York a bit it we started it many times
it got canceled here's a chance this kid
Lear DiCaprio really likes your films at
least meet with him and he was willing
to go whatever I could do to make that
film so that's how it all started with
him coming off of Titanic and a couple
of other films then we convinced Daniel
day to get into it as a Bill the Butcher
and Daniel day is very intense and very
uh specific actor and what I love about
working with him is that Daniel has a
thing where if he starts he stays in
that character people think it's kind of
a Mystique but it really makes sense and
also because if I'm talking to build a
butcher and in between takes it's Daniel
I'm still talking to Bill he stays in
that character and he'll be one of the
other actors Irish and he's not supposed
to like the Irish and you know he treats
that person that way I don't give a
company about your moral conundrum
you meat-headed sack they said why
is he asking that that that's what that
is just we're not playing I mean we're
playing but we're living it
and so he's very good that way
DiCaprio is another way entirely and he
he comes at a character from every
possible angle and we find that with Leo
most of the work is done before we shoot
Good Fellas
[Music]
as far back as I can remember I always
wanted to be a gangster Goodfellas was
made 18 years after mean streets so I
didn't really want to go to do another
genre gangster genre right I mean there
is no main character I mean Ray Liotta
is a wonderful actor and but he's like
Virgil taking Dante through the
Underworld the real character in the
movie is the underworld after doing the
film Last Temptation Of Christ when I
got back I owed Warner Brothers
Goodfellas or became Goodfellas it was
called Wise Guys at the time I didn't
really almost didn't want to make it it
was Michael Powell the director of The
Red Shoes co-director I should say and
other masterpieces who read the script
and insisted I make it every shot may
feel like a documentary but the camera
moves everything you see it's all
clearly it's all there in the script we
had to Stage bits of action Joe Reedy
did and Michael ballhouse my cameraman
they worked out all the background
action for the long Copacabana shot all
I said was we start out in the front he
gives the guy the money next thing you
know go through the thing we go through
here we go through here we go through
here we go you know we wind up on the
famous comic Kenny Youngman everything
has to flow
with no obstruction he's got to impress
her they send him bottles of champagne
everybody knows him that's his height so
that shot had to be and I wanted Joe
Pesci to be in the film and I think he
resisted it I know he resisted it he
said I don't know gangster stuff and
everything yeah but Joe I said this
character is really interesting based on
a real real guy really funny
he said well I if you do it I got to
tell you something and I said well what
is it he goes not here and he acted out
this scene that happened to him I knew
exactly where to put it went through the
scene over and over again recorded it
all each take and then I created from
the actors improvisations and try to
make sure that it accelerated the right
way because the slightest change
you know of like why my funny uh what do
you mean I'm funny I'm not funny
otherwise it would be just repetitious
funny like I'm a clown I amuse you
I make you laugh I'm here to
amuse you what do you mean funny funny
how how am I funny and I decided would
just do it with two cameras we squeeze
it in on a day that wasn't scheduled the
two cameras would be white medium wide
shots
because it was important to see not just
there are no close-ups it was important
to see Joe's character and raise
character in relation to the people
around them and while the intensity
builds you see the body language
everybody around them change and it just
happens and I said well that's even
better you know so close-ups no let's
get out of here you know we shot it like
an hour and a half it improvised to with
the bottle breaking on on Tony dyro's
head and that sort of thing he had the
nerve to ask to pay the bill
[Music]
guys you tuned up
they're connected down Providence
what they're gonna do
is come back with some guys and kill you
I always wanted to work but Jack
Nicholson being a film and they offered
him the part and then he said you know
give me something to play and he was
right because the way the script was a
bill Monahan script which is a very good
script but the character Costello was
still presented as your generic Big Shot
gangster he hears this young kid in town
who just beat up somebody in a bar he
calls him in
checks him out and then he says come and
talk to me because he looks at him and
said maybe I can use this kid we've seen
that scene many times in westerns and
gangster films because it's very
truthful that's what happens you could
do it in business too suddenly make a
big hit with something and everybody
calls you and they want to see what you
can do for them in this case it's the
underworld and there was a scene where
he's eating a lobster lunch it said in
his apartment and he has this kid coming
but basic line was what can you do for
me but you want to work with me you're a
tough guy what can you do for me I'd
seen that scene many times and Nicholson
said what if call me it's what if while
we're at lunch on the table in a little
plastic bag is a severed human hand I
said no that's a job interview and you
never mention it don't even discuss it
we went off on a whirlwind of the fact
that Costello would be losing control
and in a sense losing his mind really
that's something that was very
controversial at the time some people
remember that some didn't but the thing
was that I I was around a situation like
that when I was growing up where
somebody very powerful who was
eventually killed in 1968 was
in fact losing his mind and killing
people an atmosphere of fear that I saw
around that area that was what I wanted
to capture and departed worse than that
these guys were all informers on each
other
and it's true in a world where everyone
is informing on each other now complain
about the guy as well he's out of his
mind he's overdoing no that's imagine
that's in effect what it would be like
you're completely under
um his control and he's out of his mind
and that's what I feel the world is like
right now
[Music]
Raging Bull
it should be with everything you got I
want you to lay me out go ahead
you're sure all right
the 70s Studio system changed a great
deal and the week that film was released
was the same week from the same studio
and Michael tremino's Heaven's gate
opened that A Raging Bull Apocalypse Now
ball from the same Studio United Artist
that ended what the seven days they call
this you know Golden Age Etc but really
it ended it ended the power of um the
director in a way in American filmmaking
and that had to come back through
independent cinema
another way through the 80s the 70s was
very much that way because things were
wide open and we went in and we took it
like The Barbarians at the gate and we
transformed whatever we could but they
caught us Reggie bull was a uh we threw
everything we knew into it not knowing
how it was going to be received we
understood that people didn't like him
and even the crew turned out I didn't
know until later why am I making a film
about this guy he's a horror and but we
stayed with it this man may be this way
but still is a human being he's got a
heart he's got a soul by the end of it
he finds some kind of peace with himself
and maybe the others around him I think
I was going there to try to find peace
in myself that year there were I think
four more films coming out about boxing
the the main event with Barbra Streisand
prize fighter with Tim Conway Matilda
the boxing kangaroo and Rocky II also
and they're all in color that's when I
realized that we should go black and
white and also the black and white would
work a distinctively different from the
other boxing films that were being made
comedies and and Rocky II and also um
Irwin Winkler pointed out to the studio
that the films that were made in black
and white up to that point in the 70s
were Paper Moon and Lenny and they were
hits I also thought too that the boxing
scenes had to be very powerful the rest
of the film anything else was
concentrated and almost meditative state
in terms of framing
holding those people in that frame but
the boxing scenes would be like you're
on another planet primarily it was based
on I came up with the idea what I was
doing Last Waltz
on the stage with the band and I
watching how the band worked the ballet
sequences from red shoes
where you don't really necessarily go
head to toe we see the dancer instead
you see what's inside the mind of the
dancer what's in the mind what's the
perception of the fighter in the ring
they don't even know where they are
sometimes
The Wolf of Wall Street
[Music]
again like Raging Bull I didn't want to
make it but I had to find my own way in
it and a lot of it to do with style the
style I felt originally was more like
Goodfellas I had done it and I did it
again in Casino what more could I bring
to it and we found a way and that was
ultimately through his character and the
whole idea of untethered
capitalism this is the spirit of it
anything goes because you're making
money doesn't matter that's a little bit
that way too in casino but Casino has
organized crime it's a different thing
this is organized another way and so
with that understanding that I was able
to play with the structure of it and
make it right away first three or four
minutes of the film you can see right
away this is going to be something
unexpected like every other shot
something shocking going on in a way or
supposedly shocking in order to do that
you have to have somebody who's playing
that part be prepared to do anything and
he did I would provoke him he provoked
me would go further if you read the book
we could have gone even further
[Music]
Mean Streets
fine keep your mouth shut and you told
me not in front of this I was
living in the late 50s into the early
60s down in my old neighborhood of what
they used to call Little Italy at that
time it really was a Little Italy
families were loving but you know was it
was the tenements and it was a not a
really good place and they were good
people but at the same time it was
steeped in a kind of organized crime
Mean Streets comes out of that violence
which I missed by chance really Now's
the Time
I was with these people in this car I
told my friends with me we're in the
back seat
it's two o'clock in the morning this is
nonsense let's go home yeah yeah okay
let's go home car drove off and they got
shot
had to do with a lot of discreet power
so to speak a sense of certain rules
that the underworld works with and a lot
of it had to do with and My Brother's
Keeper it also reflects my father and
his youngest brother my father was one
of eight children his youngest brother
was always in jail always in trouble and
my father was always trying to broker uh
situations where he wouldn't get killed
there's about 30 dollars it's always got
on a Michael
where's the rest yeah where's the rest
the extent to which one is your real
brother or one is such a close friend
that you put yourself on the line is
something that's really important to me
in terms of how you live a life and try
to live a
good moral life but you're in a world
that is completely corrupt you don't
make up for your sins in the church
you do it in the streets you do it at
home and that's that's the essence of
Mean Streets that's what I talked about
in the beginning you know you can go to
church all you want but the real acting
out of your morality is outside the
church it's outside the building of the
church it's in the home it's with your
friends and that all the rest is an
illusion almost five years old in New
York it was late 40s my we had a
television 16 inch on Friday nights
there was a an Italian film shown for
the Italian-American community and my
grandparents would come over and uh they
didn't speak English only Sicilian and
my mother and father my uncles and we
get around this little TV set and we see
The Bicycle Thief it had these words in
the bottom the people that were speaking
in the film they were speaking the same
way as my family those Italian films
were more than Cinema they were a form
of Truth that I related to because it it
somehow had something to do with who I
who I am and so no matter what I shoot
uh it isn't directly saying oh we're
going to do a shot now from The Bicycle
Thief no it's the emotional and and uh
psychological impact of experiencing
that film when I was five or six in the
room with these people who lived it
the Irishman I don't I don't know it
sounds funny it stops and starts and
loses power
if I can give me a hand over the years
seeing the the difference in the
technology one of the key things to give
us the energy to make our first films
features was John cassavetes doing
shadows in 16 millimeter which came from
France with the eclair camera so all of
that happening at that time made it that
we could make a film ourselves we didn't
have to have the studio behind us with
giant lights and giant Mitchell bnc's
I've kind of stayed pretty much
traditional we edit now with the
computer but I don't really know how to
do that Thelma does it if I can utilize
the new technology
for the kind of story I want to make why
not go there and so in the case of the
Irishman De Niro and I had this idea for
a long time and again I didn't want to
do another gangster genre part of the
problem was flashbacks
and by the time we got to do it he was
too old to play his younger self and
they said Well a different actor and I
said what's then what's not like us
making a film together what's the point
and so we were talking about this idea
of uh youthification and Pablo Herman of
ilm was with us doing CGI or background
material for us in Taiwan where we're
doing silence and he came up and he said
I think I can do it what I have seen is
that people have to wear golf balls on
their faces you can't have a scene with
Joe Pesci and Bob De Niro and Al Pacino
whatever they all have golf balls on
their faces and they're the kinds of
actors that that kind of thing for this
kind of movie it doesn't work and
eventually by the end of the shoot of
Silence he had it and we did a test with
Bob and we we're De Niro and we tried it
and we all felt strongly about it the
drawback was the financially
because it was extremely expensive and
also length of time it was an extra five
to six months in the post-production
that's when Netflix came in and really
helped us it's not just CGI we accept it
if a person puts on a fat suit
or you paint their hair white or they're
supposed to be old but what if you do it
digitally
it's like makeup it's just taking that
leap of of saying oh no it's got to be
what the old way to this is this is now
the transformation into a new way
silence
[Music]
things that happen when I was making
Last Temptation that took me only up to
a certain point I found myself wanting
more and I found it in silence and when
I read the book I was in Japan actually
it was 1989 and I tried to write a
version of the script with my friend Jay
Cox by 1990 92 but I didn't get it and
it took me years another 10 12 years to
live a life and experience with
different exploration going making
kundun for example on the Dalai Lama all
of these things and finally by around
2006 2007 I was able to put the script
together I felt that we we could do it
too many technical business problems and
almost made it impossible to get made
but eventually it did Ong Lee's group
helped us
start shooting Taiwan you know a special
experience for the entire crew making
the film The locations the people the
scenes themselves what the Japanese
actors I mean it was really a kind of
spiritual journey
kill us the flower Moon their time is
over
it's taken six years we didn't intend to
take it six years but I was making the
Irishman and then there was covet was
given the book and read the book and I
was very excited by that I didn't quite
know how to go about it Eric Roth and I
went through a process of a few years of
pulling the script together and the
story and there's some wonderful things
and we got it to a point where we said
let's sit down and read this thing I got
some friends we sat down Leah was there
Eric it's good but there was something
about it that I felt we've been there
before and that was the idea of a police
procedural and the character he was
supposed to play Tom white was a
character that is straight laced you
know very strong very proper guy and so
we thought about it for another week and
a half and then Leo came to me so
where's the real he came to me where's
the real heart of this picture I said
the heart is with this guy Earnest and
his wife Molly the only problem is we
don't know anything about an artist
everybody else who've got tons of
material on we don't know anything about
him so we came up with the idea of what
if instead of coming from the outside in
what if we go from the inside out then I
said oh yeah the story really is the
relationship of Ernest and Molly and the
Betrayal I said the only problem there
is that it's a creative problem which is
you take the script you turn inside out
and how much a procedural do you need
not very much it started to come
together it gave me the direction that I
felt comfortable in
the other way I've seen the kind of
moves I enjoy doing and imagine doing
horses and running Western tropes in a
way they call it I would love that but
I've seen and they did it so much better
everybody else does it better so here
though you're in the house and there's a
husband and wife and
this guy is dodgy he's being manipulated
by this sort of Angel of Death his uncle
[Music]
okay you got a nice color scheme
what color would you say that is
my color we had been working on the
casting for quite a while including uh
indigenous people says I have somebody I
want you to see but then I saw the scene
from certain women Kelly reichardt's
film I thought she was wonderful and
after covid we got to meet I was struck
by the uh a whole Visage the face and
her intelligence one could see that
there's a lot going on in her face but
her not doing very much which is perfect
for film acting also the intelligence
and level of of understanding and coming
from indigenous people and being an
activist we could learn from her which
is what we did and we all worked
together myself her and Leo very very
closely